Jetts welcome welcome to the show bit
play this is a fun this is a really fun
show really fun idea when I watch it I I
was like I know this I know this story
Amelia any anyone that's been like an
actor working after auditioning in the
city especially you know a person of
color you've gone through you know you
know the respect so this is every story
in here has got to come from real
experiences that you guys have had yeah
yes exaggerated a little bit but for the
most part it's exactly what it is is
what it is and we just wrote from truth
right and just had a bunch of fun with
it so when did the like one of the idea
of this happened like how did it all
come to pass okay so there was a point
in my life where I was just going out
for the same roles as we know as we were
all talking about same roles over and
over again and I was like man what would
a show with no white people look like
okay let me try that and I built it up
and then I built it off more of the
relationship between me and one of my
dearest friends Nigel here I was like
two guys who came from second city and
we were the people of color in those
casts so there was a level of connection
there but we more connected just being
nerds just loving nerd stuff so I was
like I want to see a show just about
that yeah well it's a show that may come
across as a show about diversity but to
us was really just a show about reality
just about two friends living together
and going through these experiences so
it kinda it was birthed out of like this
level of frustration and then I was like
wait a minute there's a lot of jokes
here let's not be too frustrated let's
laugh it up so then Nigel no I just
would get together every once in a while
and he'd shoot out ideas and then it
would just sort of organically grow from
that yeah but yeah it was really all to
just based off of like just real life
experience yeah funny thing that I I
thought that I had watching was like you
know a lot of people will talk about it
and go this is a story of people of
color trying to break into the you know
acting or whatever it isn't and the
stories that come out of it are all
people of color stories and we're
talking about diversity we're talking
about diversity but when you're a person
of quality you're not talking about that
versity it's just your life like you're
just living your life and just living
your experience this boom dude that's
exactly
exactly like the premise of the show and
so you guys have been I mean you've been
in the scene for a very very long time
you know if any of these guys go back
and look at and even films are a shot in
Toronto commercials TV shows you guys
have been a part of a lot of this stuff
yeah yeah so what is been your
experience I mean even if you could
encapsulate it a little bit like your
experience working against I guess a
system in a way that kind of sees people
of color as only a particular thing at a
particular time right I mean I really
just think take it from the point of
view that I'm just gonna be the best
person for the job I was gonna have the
most fun and be the person that
hopefully the the client wants right and
I mean I fortunately have had times
where they've the clients I've had to
slightly change the casting because of
like oh we like this guy a bunch and we
can see that happening so that's where I
come from and I love I love having that
opportunity and I love just like you
know blowing the doors open and just
like let's let's do this let's have a
great time yeah let me give you
something that you didn't think you're
gonna get should not be the black guy
who's this or the black guy who's that
just be me doing this thing ya know on
our show we celebrate a lot of what
entertainment is about right and like
weird it kind of in one award season
right now so a lot of is like the big
the clips the glam the awards and all
that but you know that's like the one of
the endgame steps which you guys are
talking about in the show is it's
specifically from the first episode is
like walking in the door at that first
step of walking in the door and getting
noticed or trying to addition for a part
and people don't know that you don't see
that the general population yeah as
actors it's all you kind of talked about
right was it the idea like the
opportunity to share this with the
viewer like guys this is what we go
through that was appealing you guys 100%
I think so I think it was just it's the
it's the behind the scenes look of
everybody loves movies television shows
whatever but it's really nice to see
that behind the scenes look of how it
all operates and the functions of
everything and the protocol of going in
to a room the field that people probably
look like you they're all going over the
lines you ought to sign in and the
minutiae of everything and
and then really encapsulating that idea
of people a bunch of people who make
decisions that see you for a microsecond
and then they have to see you for a
microsecond and then you know maybe 50
to 100 other people for a microsecond
yeah and then make those decisions based
on that but then having fun with that
idea of like oh this is just our
day-to-day let's live it up a bit and
just say you know this is kind of
heightened reality so mm-hmm and that
microsecond you have to show them
everything you got and you have to show
them your version of that character yeah
so you have to make that big choice to
make that big leap and hopefully that's
the that's the thing that binds you
that's the thing that those decision
makers like yeah we like that yeah but
then it could be like that well you
think you know you're gonna and as
afters you spend hours before the job
going remember there's and then you're
in the room for a microsecond and then
after the job you spend hours going yeah
you guys you said that you connected on
just kind of being nerds like like nerdy
culture and and dirty fun comes what are
the things that you guys love that's
like like video games or geeky movies or
TV shows I fell in love by just trading
video game soundtracks back and forth
soundtracks video games yeah I was his
understudy at Second City so when Chris
made it onto the main stage I was his
understudy so whenever he was out I
would come in for him and so yeah one
day when we were going through a
walkthrough and you know I did I did my
things like okay let me give you some
notes and then we just yeah BAM just
hitting it off I can remember how we got
into it yeah that was it and we just
started talking about video game
soundtracks before that because we did a
class together
oh this nice small intimate okay so
given you guys love all those things for
your money what is the best comic book
movie adaptation oh you were just
talking about I recently saw Joker yeah
and I was very impressed with that
I really liked that I like Watchmen too
stuff
yeah like Watchmen I'm a big fan of the
MCU I like how they just I like I like
how the fire I like how they did it I
like how they did it and I think that
was such a smart move
I think endgame was a great way to end
this massive juggernaut of a story so I
mean yes there were liberties but a lot
of the fundamentals and bits and pieces
were taken from the actual source
material which you can read but it's
just a deep that's a deep dive right
that's I mean it took them 10 years but
that's to read all that stuff like
centuries worth of stuff yeah the call
together to make movies write something
that they've been really applauded for
is their diversity is the diversity of
actors that they have in or in their
films and movies and you know with Black
Panther and love the other superior
characters we talk about kids being able
to see themselves on screen
you guys have an episode about that too
because well that includes that which is
really hilarious but do you see that as
as a big stepping stone as sort of like
a door opening for young performers of
diverse backgrounds that really want to
get in there and see themselves out
there and go you don't me begging you
right now huge yeah I've never seen a
Pakistani guy on screen and then I saw
one in the Star Wars movie I was like oh
my god that guy's from Pakistan that's
from Pakistan and then Kumail Nanjiani
now he's getting all ripped yeah to be
in the internals you know a 39 year old
man now I could have used that when I
was younger but still it was like to see
that happening now is like this is great
this isn't exactly what we need I lost
my mind when I saw a black panther I saw
two or three times in the theater
because I just I could not get over the
fact that I wasn't watching a
documentary about Africa it was actually
a superhero movie based on a black
superhero that I grew up reading but I
didn't attach myself with because I was
like I don't know how real this is this
doesn't feel like a thing I think this
can't be a thing that's a thing and not
to see it again to your point a lot
older now could usually you when I was
younger but I'm down like it's so great
to see that yeah so it season two gonna
deal with you know you wanted to get
ripped for a superhero role or anything
like that like what
do you have ideas bouncing around for
what the next season of the show might
look like definitely I think it's a lot
of just the repercussions of decisions
made in the first season for both
characters yeah
because it really boils down to you know
as much as we wanted to hit into nerd
culture and diversity and bringing all
that to the forefront I was really like
good Nigel and I talked about this it's
got to be about these two guys like
what's the very interesting thing that's
four heart of this and it's the
friendship between these two guys so he
thought it was like more of a Nouveau
kind of odd couples that one guy's a
very working professional and wants to
be an actor and spends all this time
preparing for that and the other guy's a
full-time stoner and wants to do that
and just the ideas of growing up and the
repercussions of decisions and moving
forward like that dealing with our
family there's those mentions of family
members and stuff in the first season
but we were like let's see those in the
second season where we come from and
where these characters how they turned
into who they are
so CBC Jem huh a bunch of episodes are
dropped right away right ten minutes
each
is it kind of nerve-wracking that you
get people to watch the entire season in
one go yeah I think so you're kind of
like you have this baby then you go go
baby
people watch the baby now and then
you're just kind of sitting there - what
does everyone think of the baby is the
baby any good yeah so it is very
nerve-wracking but fought in - because
you spent so much time with this baby
and then you're like okay baby go free
all right and you think the baby has
legs I think the baby is laying are mean
you're used to creating we used to
writing and performing given your
background how is how is this different
and and did you feel like a real sense
of I guess power coming from
understanding the perspective of your
characters right I think I think the
best part for me when it comes to that
is the idea that we will the fact that
we came from an improv background and
because we were you know we did the
Second City thing we did it so intensely
and we made it onto the main stage so
you have this this this shorthand and we
had a very good rapport with each other
so when I when we were writing these
scripts it was easy for us to just shut
the laptop down and just improvise the
moment and literally across the table
for each other
and improvise the moment and then wait
what was that thing you said and then
we'll just open it up and once you write
it back so that was stressful but it was
easy yeah no and then who's just getting
the notes and then doing it again yeah
again so it's just that repetitiveness
and thinking deeper and making the
characters different cuz they were the
same at first they're kind of linear you
know they're kind of parallel yeah yeah
then now there's there's so much so much
meat to them yeah and when you're
actually on the day shooting how much of
what you wrote did you stick to or do
you actually you know and provides a
bunch of this stuff when you're out
there yeah that was actually a really
big point we thought about is like let's
let's really embrace that idea is that
we we do have the luxury of just messing
around and improvising and we give each
other those moments we can find those
little moments but it was more built on
this idea of like we're building
episodes so we can stick to the scenes
and let's get the words out but let's
feel comfortable with it first and then
start to mess around with each other and
get those really candid moments so
there's really real moments so it was
sort of working off the skeleton that we
built at first and then once we're there
on the day going okay how much time do
we have left
can we play around a little bit or can
we add a bit more lines to this
character or whatever so it's really
great it was really fun and then working
with the trustworthy team and the
amazing team that we were working with
it was everything was just really easy
and everyone was having fun yeah it
looks like it reads when you watch the
show what was it like actually getting
to be the bosses essentially like this
is your thing highly suggest it was
great it was fantastic I think I think
just just to Chris's point having such a
great team behind us yeah it was easy
for us to all get on the same page and
throw ideas out and and there was no
hard-nosed you know is like okay cool
sure let's try it but I can only give
you this much time or whatever let's do
it so so we had a lot of stuff to play
with which is great and then just being
able to you know use our creativity and
use that and
rising background just okay we'll get to
the point we just want to change the
words so there's a lot of fun that way a
lot of fun yeah it's cool to be on set
and tell people what to do you know
that's one thing we'll use great thank
you sir